hice un viaje nómada donde solía vivir
en mi automóvil con un tiro libre en
lugar de estar pegado a estructuras
sociales y las hegemonías de la sociedad
[Aplausos]
usan aplicaciones de citas
ya
[Risas]
[Música]
que les impide utilizar aplicaciones de
citas los locos al los chicos no
puedes sentir su energía que es lo peor
que un chico puede poner en su perfil de
citas una foto pescando
aquí vienen o no tengo un chicle
[Risas]
[Música]
son muchos sí muchos
hola soy and bear tengo 22 años
colecciona monedas prensadas y las de 51
centavos son mis favoritas
soy mckenzie tengo 21 años y un millón
de personas me vieron besarme con un
chico en línea
[Risas]
soy iab y tengo 20 años soy fotógrafa de
bodas de destino a tiempo completo y su
instructora de yoga aparte soy de un
condado amish en pensilvania
tengo niños menonitas y amis en mi casa
hola soy victoria tengo 26 años soy
influyente en las redes sociales estoy
soltera así que estoy lista para una
ciudad
mi nombre es ya aquí tengo 19 disfruto
pasar el tiempo libre en el gimnasio
comencé hace poco entonces estamos en
sucre 5
adelante bien lo llevamos primer paso
aquí vamos a la
persecución asiática
[Risas]
[Música]
hola hola
bien estoy bien todo está bien cómo les
ha ido hoy empezamos ahora mismo
cómo estás desde cayó algo creo que era
tus estándares soy yo
gracias por estar ahí
es la primera vez que conoces a tres
chicos de la nada
díganme un número favorito del 1 al 13
673 estás libre en septiembre no
recuerdo el día tengo una boda si
necesitas una cita sí en san diego si
quieres ir tengo familia en un pequeño
pueblo de pensión de en myers town lo
conoces si no está tan lejos de hecho
soy un cineasta independiente
o estás contando también
tienes una buena figura con qué
frecuencia vas al gimnasio como cinco
veces a la semana pareces fuerte como
para cargar mi bagaje emocional o vaya
qué historia tienen para contar como una
vez hice esto por ejemplo yo una vez me
uní a un culto fue sin querer fue sin
querer pero simeón y me gusta el
color favorito que me adivinar no estoy
entre el azul y verde creo que es como
un estándar claro no me gustan las
charlas algo sobre mí me lesioné una vez
y como resultado comenzó a ser más choca
involucrarme con la naturaleza hice un
poco de yoga kundalini
lo siento teléfono antes de empezar no
no
una persona en un minuto
[Risas]
yo tu culo para un orquestado me encanta
el cello no gm o resumirlos y laptops o
de hecho si tienes razón sobre esas tics
y le gusta el té
ya sea lo que llames dios o el universo
o el origen sigue siendo amor y la
conexión como sociedad 1
543 2
probablemente los voy a eliminar a él
sí
me siento mucho estoy bien pero bueno
tengo tantas opciones distintas no sé a
quién voy a elegir lo siento pero tú no
has hablado muchos siglos el del medio
tienes un minuto más y luego debes
eliminar a uno no eres una especie de
espíritu libre nómada o te gusta la
estabilidad y tener ese balance
cuál es tu tipo de cuerpo de agua
favorita el océano las olas van y vienen
como la luna influye sobre muchas cosas
solo estoy inventando cosas para que
ellos no tengan tiempo de hablar de qué
nacionalidad de vietnam y tiene el
estilo soy chino y filipinos soy
filipino filipina adivina a chino de
linden de lenin de hacer ejercicio hace
poco fue muy difícil entonces nunca
estuve en forma y un día fui con uno de
mis amigos al gimnasio y dije hagamos
esto elimina a alguien está o no puede
ser no puede ser
no puede ser respira profundo
puedo quedarme con los otros 23
lo siento mucho está bien
lo siento
mucha suerte lo siento te voy a eliminar
está bien y tuve un placer de saber
bueno amigo bien un minuto más hice un
viaje nómada donde solía vivir en mi
automóvil bien porque debería elegiste
porque debería subirme soy muy
susceptible a la presión de grupo lo que
diga seguro funcionará soy un día
necesitas dormir con un pianista el
próximo año estaría ahí me gusta fluir y
escuchar mi intuición e ir a donde sea
deberías escoger me porque puedo cocinar
lo que sea que quieras que cocine para
hoy también toco la guitarra y el cello
dijiste que te encandiló de lanchile
este tipo no toca el cielo rayos
eliminar es no lo puedo creer voy a
vomitar está bien
bien bien bien bien solo respiro
profundo y el reloj
en realidad creo que me voy a quedar
para hablar contigo porque siento que ya
he hablado mucho contigo corre gustaría
escuchar los que tengan un feliz día a
mí nos abrazamos hauché y me encantaría
una plaza bien
qué opinan de la experiencia en general
eso fue estresante pararse ahí esperar
quién te escogerá y por qué lo hicieron
probablemente solo en base a la
atracción inicial porque en realidad no
sabes nada sobre el otro aún estar al
lado de una chica bonita es increíble me
hace sonreír como ahora todos eran muy
buenos todos tenían muy buenas
cualidades
gracias por eso y pienso que pasa así
sin ofender qué pasa si me equivoqué
creen que tal vez se reúnan para pasar
el rato fuera de esta sesión
si definitivamente me gustaría mucho eso
bueno me parece bueno estoy buscando a
alguien con quien hacer ejercicio así
bueno honestamente no me gusta hacer
ejercicio con otras personas así que tal
vez eso no pero
si genial
si puedes venir pasamos el rato la está
bien iré para ya un día justo en
conocerlo en conocerte
que hay amigos hagamos esto
como va todo bien va fenomenal si
siempre es un excelente día mi amigo qué
te pareció la experiencia fue más como
yo queriendo sacar a relucir mis
experiencias y similitudes que veía en
ella sólo quería que ella la supiera fue
algo así sí fue genial
[Música]